are there people in Show Business you're
close with where you do have their
number and you call them and you say hey
I'm going through something now I you
know I didn't expect Fame to be like
this are there is there someone that you
confide in that you have real mad
respect for I'll say this the first
person who ever talked to me like that
was Adele like Adele was like lizao she
called me like how do you [ __ ] do it
like you know she was literally like how
are you doing this like when she first
came out you know the the culture of
music and being an artist was so
different especially what you were
saying to social media and she was just
like are you okay do you want to come
over and drink some wine do you want to
talk and I was like yeah so you know
Adele has like you know she's literally
me in a different font so like it's nice
to have her and like even her like
shouting out my documentary at her show
the other day was like really sweet and
she didn't have to and she texted me
like I [ __ ] hate documentaries unless
you're Tina Turner or the Beatles I mean
this was so [ __ ] good and I was like
thank you and that's that's so great
though isn't it that you have someone
like that who you can turn to yeah like
that and I look up to her a lot like
she's done a lot and she knows who she
is and she Honors that with every album
and she gives us piano ballads that go
number one which is just like so hard
and rare to do you just have to be like
the rarest gym of all time to be able to
do that we need her I'm grateful for her
would you be into a collaboration with
her has she ever brought that up
we've never talked about that
um I you know what I would do with Adele
I would play flute right I would play
flute with Adele because she's that kind
of artist you know